ho intervistato Steven Spielberg io non
so neanche come descrivere questa cosa
perché Spielberg cioè Spielberg non è
Apps Spielberg Spielberg quindi è stato
per me molto difficile siccome io non
parlo bene l'inglese e mi sono studiato
mi sono studiato bene la frase da dire è
stato difficilissimo per me e secondo
voi quale domanda potrò mai aver fatto
a step lo scoprirete tra poco questa è
l'intervista
Favij nessuno insieme
mai più questa è una battuta Today ahi A
Different Question Ehm io no pineapple
pizza perché infame Music
quindi direi di sì Ehm guardo you think
about and whites
quindi ragazzi Questa è stata la mia
esperienza con Spielberg e
Simpaticissimo tra l'altro è una persona
d'oro davvero abbiamo chiacchierato un
po' non vi ho messo tutto ho tagliato un
po' però è veramente simpatico e abbiamo
intervistato per l'occasione dell'uscita
del suo nuovo film che era di Player One
che tra l'altro se non l'avete visto
andate a vederlo che è veramente figo
niente per il resto del blog vi faccio
vedere che cosa ho fatto durante la
settimana visto che siamo andati in
montagna ed è successo un casino come
sempre Vabbè dai ragazzi non vuole non
vuole essere intervistato perché non non
richiede quanti like per Gianluca inizio
video 100.000 100.000 di 100.000 like
arrivano Ti prego ricordati che il mio
personaggio è venuto esatto
di 100.000 like
[Musica]
quanti mila like per il bolide con cui
stiamo andando a Piani di Bobbio Ma sta
Lamborghini
Lamborghini di Gianluca
Siamo arrivati a Bobbio piene di Bobbio
Piani di Bobbio Cagliari
[Musica]
abbiamo oggi un sistema di sicurezza
all'avanguardia qua a Bobbio che
recensiremo vieni Sasha è tipo gli
aeroporti Oh mio Dio non ho il biglietto
come passo
è un hacker
barbonde perché non pagare Allora non
c'è neanche il controllo bagagli
manca un mammut ci passa Lì in mezzo ma
scusami
vip basta
Aspettatemi che non sono un Balto un
Baldo giovane un ballo giovane Oh la
prendi il sole al limite se uno deve
andare in montagna lontano dalla civiltà
è lontano dalla civiltà si deve trovare
sti elementi qua Allora ragazzi hai
mandato la chiave dell'hotel Cioè nella
stanza dell'hotel e mi hanno detto che
al secondo piano la mia stanza già che è
buio mi dia male in più la chiave il
numero 13
e l'ambientazione la stessa di venerdì
13 quindi siamo a posto
era Madonna
che c'è laggiù Spero che non sia laggiù
la mia stanza se non è un problema
A 14
13 questa
Mister cally veramente mi chiamo Favij
però ci sono andati vicino dai
Ma che è la ragazza ideale di questa Ma
cos'è che figata sembra Oh mio Dio tipo
in Minecraft qua sei un accendino è un
casino Eh porca vacca che figata e la
luce
[Musica]
non c'è la luce cago al buio letto per
friendzonati però tanto non è che devo
dormire Tudor quindi va benissimo è la
vista in teoria La vedrete voi perché
non ci arrivo e questa
non so cosa abbiate visto però quando io
sono in trasferta Quindi quando dormo
fuori mi porto il computer portatile per
lavorare no perché
devo fare i video faccio il video al
giorno Quindi faccio i video col portati
quando prendo un hotel Insomma roba del
genere portatile mi metto sulla
scrivania e monto i video Lorenzo Prima
mi ha detto questo portati materiale per
lavorare perché hai tempo e spazio della
serie portati il computer così riesce a
fare i video in camera ok sia tempo che
lo spazio per farlo ora
dove sta minchia ce lo vedi lo spazio
per fare i video Spiegami portatile non
lo posso mettere lì perché ci vuole il
mouse le cuffie Cioè non posso mettermi
sul letto a fare sta roba impossibile
l'unica
pseudo scrivania dovrebbe essere questa
che però ci sta a malapena un
telecomando
spiegami come ci fa stare il portatile
con tutto l'ambaradan non lo so Io
niente raga stiamo seguendo Tudor che ha
già lasciato i bisogni per terra perché
Comunque stiamo andando in escursione io
perché sono spider-man Ah non lo sapevo
non avrei mai detto quello cammina come
se fosse
Corri la figura Figurati No vabbè ma
guarda
è divertente morire così no raga è
fattibile ve lo giuro
e niente Lorenzo ha un modo suo per
scendere le montagne perfetto
Dai che ci sei quasi la frattura è
vicina io non so come commentare questa
cosa che sta per succedere però la
riprendo non si sa mai Vabbè se va male
YouTube e cerco di imparare come si fa
lo Stuntman
già malissimo
aiuto
Guarda che che strisciata
[Musica]
Madonna che male
[Risate]
non avevo dubbi
già malissimo
[Musica]